all right well good morning all uh
welcome to the simons institute uh my
name is peter bartlett i'm the associate
director here
and and welcome to the
second workshop in the learning games
program that's running this semester
learning in the presence of strategic
behavior
um a big thank you to the nsf for its
support of this uh this program this
semester
thanks also to the organizers uh for
putting together a great program for
this week so giorgios pilluras fei fang
nica hug talab christos papa dimitrio
bacilla surcanus and eva tardos big
thank you to those folks
um so
just a few a few little logistics
matters so so uh you get food and and
coffee and so on during the breaks for
lunch you're on your own
there are many places on around campus
you can go to
please leave the food and drinks outside
masks are strongly recommended but not
not obligatory
at lunch time you can go leave your
stuff in lockers on the far side of the
building on this level and there's a pin
code that works those
and we have a hybrid format so
everything's
also on zoom uh and uh i mean fire
videographer is uh going to help the
speakers uh with hooking up their
computers and
and setting up microphones and so on
uh
also a big thank you to kelani penland
who's in the back up here did all the
local local arrangements thanks karen
[Applause]
all right i'll leave you to it enjoy the
week would you
thank you
okay everybody uh hi and uh welcome to
our workshop on learning in the presence
of uh strategic behavior
so in this workshop we'll be covering a
diverse set of themes
we're interested both in
human behavior as well as in machine
learning systems
and for example would be
examining a diverse set of topics like
for example
how to learn with humans in the loop
how to perform learning
when the data providers have a vested
interest in the outcome of the learning
process
learning uh as a game theoretic solution
concept
and also econometrics like analyzing
data
from strategic interactions so to cover
all these
diverse topics
we have assembled uh
a great cast of experts from
computer science game theory
uh economists both applied and
theoretical also people from industry so
we're looking forward to a very exciting
week and i'm very very happy
to announce the our first peter speaker
to kick us off
when i got married
he's a
senior researcher from cnrs and he'll be
talking today about the limits of
regularized learning in games thank you
so much panagioti all right
the floor is yours okay thank you jorgo
thank you thank you
a big thank you to the organizing
committee also of the
of this program uh always a pleasure
to be here
and uh yeah so
uh to start us off i should probably say
that uh this is actually joint work with
uh among others uh server one of the
organizers
uh and uh also uh aguilitano uh another
vladis and uh bill sandholz who
unfortunately passed away
in
last year um
so
what is this going to be about what is
this going to be about
i'm not going to spend too much time on
motivating uh uh on motivating uh the
the talk the whole uh game theoretic uh
learning paradigm and all that uh the
idea is that uh you know
uh
either as
humans either as algorithms like google
trying to suggest they're out or whatnot
we are often
faced with very very complex uh
interactions
which may be simple in terms of choices
like which highway to take but very very
difficult to precisely model
uh and uh
completely uh predict so
in situations like that when you are
having your beautiful
morning commute in the in the bay area
you have a very simple choice to make
which uh which route you would like to
take from home to work
but
you are also facing an unknown number of
other commuters
uh with unknown preferences unknown uh
basically everything is unknown so what
we'd like to see here
is uh exactly
how
what we can expect in terms of uh
agents that are trying to learn uh day
by day
uh in in this repeated interaction all
right so i'm going to take a very
generic
viewpoint to begin with and i'm going to
specify it as we go along
the generic skeleton will be simply that
we have
a
decision process which repeats in time
which would be either continuous or
discrete
and at each element at each epoch of
this decision process
uh
the agents choose an action they receive
a reward maybe some additional feedback
and the process repeats so on and so
forth
now uh here there are many there are
many modeling there are many uh modeling
choices to be made first of all in time
whether you are looking at continuous
time or discrete time learning processes
and this is a distinction that
will actually be a very crucial for
today's talk the first part of the talk
will be focused on continuous time
learning models rather whereas the
second
part will be about discrete time
uh then you have modeling choices about
the set of players whether you are
facing a continuous population of
players or just a finite set thereof uh
the same with actions whether the uh
whether the action set of a player is
continuous for instance as in many
machine learning
games like guns or discrete like
choosing a route as we said
and also
about the reward mechanism whether the
rewards are only generated through the
interactions of an agent with every
other agent in the game or
they are also exogenous meaning there is
some outward uh meaning there is some uh
uh outside mechanism like nature which
is not affected by the age by the
actions of the players but which does
affect their rewards
and what is going to be also very
crucial in the second part of the talk
is the type of feedback that we assume
that players observe in this situation
whether this is this is uh whether
agents are able to observe each other's
actions whether they are only able to
observe their own rewards or to counter
factually estimate the rewards of
actions they did not take such as for
instance if you are traveling from point
a to point b and your gps can tell you
that if you had taken
another route it would have taken you
so much time all right so all these
models all these models are quite
different and
i will try to give uh
a more or less uh synthetic
view of all of uh of at least the subset
of these processes
uh
but to avoid getting completely lost i
would say that uh we are going to focus
uh
exclusively
on games with a finite number of players
and a finite number of actions all right
so no continuous games no population
games and i'm making this distinction
because what i'm uh the type of results
that i'm going to present can actually
be very different if you change any of
these two
uh modeling assumptions and i'm not just
saying that there are some technical
conditions that need to be satisfied or
that there is there are some details
that need to be tweaked i mean
qualitatively fundamentally different
all right
so
again
uh
the learning model therefore is just as
we said before we have multiple agents
individual objectives payoffs determined
by actions of all the agents
uh the agents receive their payoffs they
adjust their actions and what we are
going to try to see is whether
a
large family of learning processes can
actually lead to stable and or rational
outcomes all right
so
to start with some uh
with some
uh definitions uh as i said we're going
to be looking exclusively at finite
games in normal form so what we have
here is a finite set of players each
with a finite set of actions
and
they paid to the players are given by
functions defined on this discrete set
which in turn defined the
action of
the the payoff to a given player given
uh
given a pure action profile as well as
the payoff vector to a player given an
action profile all right
so uh
i'm making this distinction because uh
this this type of these types of vectors
will be uh fundamental
uh i mean the payoff vectors to the
players will be fundamental in defining
the type of feedback that the players
observe so as i was saying before
if players only
if all players only observe their action
they
sorry if players only observe their
reward they only know this scalar over
here
if however they have some counterfactual
mechanism with which they could estimate
the payoffs to actions that they did not
actually play
then they may have
information
about the entire vector and if you were
here last week and you followed the
video
muthukumar's talk this is what she was
calling realization based feedback this
is just the observation of the pure
payoff vector
corresponding to an action profile
alright
there is even more information that
players could have if we go to the mixed
extension of the game where players are
no longer playing fewer actions but they
are playing
uh mixed strategies uh so probably the
distributions over their uh their pure
actions in which case we are talking
about their uh
mixed payoff and the corresponding mixed
payoff vector all right so their mixed
payoff vector captures precisely
the uh
the payoff that a player would have
gotten if they had played a specific
pure action against the mixed action of
their of their opponents
all right
so uh
this in terms of information
is actually significantly more
than
the
uh
pure payoff vector which has the counter
factual rewards
and again if i am if i were to use a
video as a terminology this is what she
called the mixture model or the
telepathic feedback because in order to
uh in order to
get an estimate for this vector you just
need to be able to somehow
counterfactually estimate the rewards
that you could have gotten against the
realized actions here you would need to
get the counterfactual rewards against
the mixture of other players strategies
so of course this type of feedback even
though it is very convenient to work
with and a lot of literature has been
uh
has focused on exactly this type of
feedback is of course quite demanding in
terms of modeling
all right
so
we'll revisit this i just want to give
you
some uh
to give you a heads up about uh some
distinctions that will play an important
role in the sequel
yes so uh the
the payoff you can read it from the
uh
picture
the payoff function if you know this for
me then yeah you can adjust the
different shapes
if you know
[Music]
does this take into account
refers to the player's individual choice
of strategy so i'm not saying i would
know what i would have gotten if i had
played something else and every other
player had also paid something else okay
no when i say that blower players know
their pure payoff vector i mean that i
know this the fail that i would have
gotten if i had played a different pure
strategy and the other players had
played the same
pure strategy okay so discounted
function with respect by individual
choice not with respect to the choice of
my opponents or the other players
make sense
our questions
all right
by the way please keep them coming
because it's much more interesting that
way
now
in terms of solution concepts what i
will primarily uh want to study is again
the notion of nash equilibrium which uh
in
i mean this is standard i will not i
will not
uh
spend too much time on it except to make
an important distinction between two
different classes or rather three
different classes of equilibria that
will end up having different properties
in terms of learning so of course i mean
an equilibrium is a strategy is a
strategy profile which is resilient to
unilateral deviations
now uh
if the equilibrium if the support of the
equilibrium in terms of mixed strategies
is a singleton
then
the equilibrium is called pure so it is
in equilibrium in pure strategies
and if
when possible i can replace the
inequalities here the weakness by a
strict inequality then the equilibrium
is called strict so in other words in a
strict equilibria uh
every play every players every player
has a unique best response to their
opponent all right
now
um
the distinction between
mixed
mixed equilibria which are equilibria
that yes
there's no noise or time variation in
this utilities like
if i observe the utility for given
action now it would get extensive
usually the next period or i'm not i
haven't talked about how players play
here we have an underlying
normal form game which doesn't change
all right this is why this is why i've
never had independence here in the
payoff functions on time
all right the game the underlying game
is fixed
so uh
we'll get to the model but yes they will
keep playing the they say
you are playing against the same game it
is not a stochastic game
where you will transition to a different
state or whatever
all right
does this answer your question okay any
more questions
all right
so
uh
yeah
geometrically
uh there is a very important distinction
between these three types of equilibria
mixed pure and strict
and
this is uh most easily seen if you look
at the so-called
variational formulation of the
equilibrium which tells you that uh at
equilibrium
the pay of the player's payoff vector is
actually pointing outwards relative to
the uh to the player's strategy space
all right so if uh so just to give you
uh some uh to
show you a picture
if we have a mixed equilibrium so it is
supported it is supported on this
strategy and let's say that strategy
over here
then
uh
the
payoff vector will always live on the
normal cone
and here which means that it will have
no component on the two supported
strategies meaning that it
which is natural i mean in in your
equilibrium strategies they need to have
the same base all right
now
in the case of a pure equilibrium the
image the picture is exactly the same
only that well the support of the
equilibrium is uh
is a singleton
what changes however geometrically in
these cases is that
the normal cone to the simplex at the
mixed equilibrium is well at the
non-corner at any non-corner point
actually has empty topological interior
which means that it has no content
topologically speaking whereas if you're
looking at the corner at the corner
point meaning at a pure at the pure
state then the normal cone actually does
have content and what this means is that
the payoff vector can actually live in
the topological interior of this of this
of this cone and this is exactly what
happens with strict equilibria their
payoff vector lives on the in the
topological interior of the normal cone
why is it significant why is this
significant because we are going to look
at processes which are trial which are
trying to
follow
the payoff vector of uh
at a given at a given state so this
means that if we are at an interior
state like that then when we are
approaching the equilibrium
any type of noise will actually
uh will actually mess up the convergence
along with the supported strategies
precisely because there is no component
there is no drift along the supported
strategy whereas here in this case
strict equilibria don't have this you
always have a very definite drift
towards this corner of the simplex and
this is already an indication that in
normal form games
strict equilibria pure equilibrium and
mixed equilibria will have uh are
expected to have very
very different convergence uh
convergence properties in this in this
regard already we see a certain
instability
in mixed equilibria all right this is
simply from a variational perspective i
haven't talked about dynamics at all
the the rest of the talk will be exactly
to see whether this instability is also
reflected in the uh in the uh
properties of uh regularized of a wide
array of learning processes in
in games
all right
so as i said
uh yeah in what are these type of
dynamical properties that we will try to
study is exactly whether
uh an equilibrium the equilibrium
concepts that we're looking at nash
equilibria well whether they are stable
attracting
under a class of learning processes and
whether the dynamics which i still
haven't defined converge locally
globally and what other behaviors we can
observe in this context and they should
start here
by managing expectations so uh
in case uh the in case you are not
familiar with this result there was a
foundational result in in the early
2000s when uh when there was a huge push
in the economy in the economics
literature to try and justify
the notion of that nash equilibrium uh
by uh learning by adaptive dynamical
processes
uh there was a unfortunately an obstacle
that
was
that cannot be overcome
and
which is the impossibility theorem of
heart and masculine
and which states very simply that there
exists no uncoupled dynamics that always
converge to nash equilibrium in every
game all right what does uncoupled
dynamics mean it means that the player's
adjustment process
only depends
could depend on the strategies of other
players but not on their payoffs because
otherwise if i allow dependence on the
payoffs i could simply write dynamic
dynamical processes a dynamical process
which is simply the distance from
equilibrium minimize that and i'm done
but this is not something that
is a reasonable learning dynamic so this
is uh this is why heart and muscular
introduced the notion of an uncoupled
and uncapital dynamical process and they
showed that there exists no
such dynamics i should say in continuous
time
which guarantee convergence to natural
equilibrium in all
in every game all right and of course
this is
sorry yes
there should be some
this doesn't exist such a dynamic what
does you know what um i claim i
i understand the question are you
certain that you can write uh even
uh
even a non-polynomial time uncoupled
process which can converge always too
much
uncoupled be careful
so there is something about polynomial
time here or there is first of all first
of all as i said this for this uh this
has to do this is a continuous time
result
all right
so in continuous time things are things
are different we don't have we don't
have any process we don't we don't
calculate the number of iterations so we
cannot really talk about the oracle
complexity of the continuous time
process that being said
the precise uh the precise and the
precise statement here is that if you
take any unknown dynamic system and
coupled in precisely this sound
uh then uh there exists a game
uh whose unique equilibrium
sorry there exists a game with a unique
equilibrium which is unstable under dia
under these dynamics all right
and since it is unstable it means that
the dynamics the dynamics in hand the
uncoupled dynamics in hand will cannot
converge to it from any initial
condition
all right this is the precise statement
of the result
all right
finding several points
um
the actual counter example uh considered
by hart and maskol
is
is
more topological it is not easier i
don't it does not it certainly doesn't
have a zero-sum structure a priori
and
i am not even sure
i'm not even uh
rather uh
in the case in the if you constrain
yourself to the subclass of min max uh
of min max finite games the theorem is
not is no longer true
because again as i said the for every
dynamics there exists a game such that
blah blah blah
no one says and heart and muscle
definitely do not say that this game
will be a mini max game
all right
yes
maybe i mean suggesting that with enough
time you could learn the payoff
functions of the other players so maybe
it's something about the information
you'll never have the right information
to
learn those things um again
again
this is where the uncoupled assumption
comes in because
let's take what you say for example that
you will learn something about the pay
the tail functions of the other players
unless unless
this learning for the other player's
player function is somehow ingrained in
your adjustment process and your
learning process unless you're actively
trying to learn something about them
then of course you won't learn anything
but this is exactly what the uncoupled
assumption says here that
uh
the adjustment the learning that you're
learning that your learning process does
not depend on the pay of functions of
other players all right
if we go if we drop this uncoupled
assumption which is actually related to
the previous question
then of course this theorem is false and
it's
trivial to write dynamics that always
converts to equilibrium in all games
but they are not uncoupled
i don't know does this answer your
question
the dynamics need to be first order if
this is like an extra state variable
that keeps lack of stuff and then it's
not enforced
uh perhaps i'm not uh expressing myself
uh clearly but if it's clear i'm very
happy
uh
right
any more questions because actually this
is this is an important thing to
understand
okay
so
let's see now what type of
i mean what type of learning dynamics we
will study in this topic how much time
do i have
until
uh so like another half an hour okay so
right
all right
okay so
uh
again the the precise model that we're
looking at is that uh
well i'll start with continuous time
dynamics and at each epoch in continuous
time players choose a mixed strategy and
for now i will assume
because this is more of a warm-up model
i will assume that they have access at
each at each epoch to the entire mixed
payoff vector
all right
so again
not realistic not super realistic
perhaps
for me this is just a warm up to see
what
what we can do with this so continuous
time finite players finite actions
mix strategies and mixed payoff vectors
as feedback
a standard uh a standard and well-known
uh type of dynamical process here is
uh
the
uh
uh is learning with exponential waves
we're all familiar familiar with x3
multiplicative weights update in
continuous time this simply uh this
simply boils down to
every player aggregating the uh the
payoffs that they get over time here for
simplicity for simplicity i've dropped
the player index just to keep things
going
and
so they aggregate them in continuous
time
and they
choose an action with probability which
is exponentially proportional to this
propensity score all right so in
particular this means that their mixed
strategy at every stage is simply this
logic function of the integrals of their
payoffs up to
up to a given point in time all right
now
uh you can differentiate uh this
function in terms of in terms of time
this is just a two line uh uh a two line
calculation and what you end up with is
a very specific
expression for uh
for the evolution of the of the players
mixed strategies over time which in the
literature is known as the replicator
dynamics and they which were originally
introduced in biology in the
late 70s and uh this link
in continuous time between uh
uh between uh exponential weights and
the replicator dynamics my knowledge was
first observed by rustic in 1999. so
this is very nice because now this maps
a reasonable learning process to a
well-defined dynamical system on the
simplex
all right
so
of course you can
play you can elaborate on this idea
and instead and note that this logit map
which defines sorry this logic map here
which defines the replicator dynamics
can actually be seen as an approximate
uh best response if instead of playing
uh the
mixed strategy that that maximizes your
uh your expected score you are uh
adjusting you are regularizing this with
the negative entropy of your uh of your
strategy okay so if you regularize
things like that uh your uh
your uh best response sorry your best
response here becomes a logic best
response and if instead of
uh an arbitrary if instead of the
negative entropy use an arbitrary
regularizer for uh for us for the moment
a strictly context continuous regular uh
function on the simplex or rather the
product of simplices
then you get a regularized best response
like that and the corresponding dynamics
are can be seen as a continuous time
analog of follow the regularized leader
all right so this is also the type of
dynamics that we're going to to look at
so
uh i mean okay if uh this is just an
example if you take if you take for
instance uh euclidean regularization you
get uh projection dynamics that's not so
i mean these examples are standard i'm
going to focus more on the type of
behaviors that you can get on different
games all right
now so first of all
let's start with 2x2 games which are
very simple to draw
then if we focus on the replicator
dynamics
you uh in a conjunction game we get
a very simple profile we get uh we have
two strict equilibria
here and here which are asymptotically
stable meaning that the dynamics
converge to them locally
and we have an interior mixed
equilibrium which is unstable
all right
if we go to a coordination game instead
of an anti-coordination game then this
situation this portrait is reversed uh
we have but topologically it is the same
it is the same we have again two strict
nash equilibria and one interior
one mixed unstable one
in
uh in in zero sum in min max two by two
games uh they
with an interior equilibrium
the situation is again different is now
topologically different because we have
an interior
uh a mixed a unique mixed equilibrium
which is not unstable however because
here at this point is i will
i will present the relative definition
but this point is what is known as japan
of stable though there is no trajectory
which actually converges to equilibrium
if unless the trajectory actually starts
at equilibrium
right and finally we have profiles like
the prisoners dilemma
which
which have a dominated strategy so all
all strategies converge to the same
to the same point all right now in two
by two games that's all
up to uh up to controversy up to
topological as a morpheme you cannot
have any other behavior in the class of
generic games all right these are these
are all the portraits that you can get
again in the class of generic games so
if you allow for for uh for a certain
pay of ties you can somehow
get some boundary pathological cases but
that's all you you have
if you start adding players however the
situation can be quite different uh
here uh is such a mess of a profile
where you see you can have trajectories
which end up converging to some type of
limit cycle over here
you can have still uh
cases of convergence to strict
equilibria or you can have a coexistence
of
uh one part of the phase space
converging to some limit cycle another
part of the phase space converging to uh
equilibrium but in all these examples
still what you see is
that
strict equilibria are always
attracting and stable
and uh here
uh
here uh
mixed equilibria well they can be
um
they have not stable but they are never
attractive
all right
you could ask whether this is due to the
regularizer that
that we're using and actually the
regularizer has nothing to do with this
type of with this type of behavior if
you change the regularizer uh for
instance because here i was talking
about the replicator dynamics up to this
point
uh we can change the regularizer being
used
and there is an entire class of
regularizers a parameterized class which
is called the the chalice the chalice
entropy which
which includes both on one end the
euclidean regularizer on the other end
the uh the standard entropic regularizer
and here if you run this on matching
penis you still get
a topology topologically the same
profile at least near an equilibrium you
still get these perfect cycles the only
difference is that with the euclidean
regularizer you can run into the
boundary in finite time
continue a bit on the boundary then
enter again the interior of the space
continue enter so on so forth
all right
this behavior actually disappears
as
the uh as you're moving towards towards
the regularizers that are steep in the
sense that their gradient explodes near
the boundary of the state space
but always you have this cyclic
behavior
around
around mixed equilibria in zero sum
games all right
so
the
i'll i'm gonna skip these slides
so
the goal will be to is to see whether
there is an underlying principle
here
and uh it is at this point that i would
like to define some of the notions that
i was using like japanese stability and
asymptotic stability so first of all to
begin with uh japono stability what this
means is you say that the state is not
stable if whenever the dynamics
start close enough to the state then
they remain close enough to set stage
all right this is the notion of
relational stability and sometimes the
hapunov is dropped and we just stay
stable
all right
more interesting perhaps a point is
attracting if whenever the dynamics
start close enough to it then they
eventually converge to the point in
question and if it has both
uh the stability and attractive
properties then the point is called
asymptotically stable
all right
so
this is then the main result
in continuous time
it tells you the following
that for any finite game
and for any
uh for any of this class of regularized
learning processes in continuous time
the following is true first of all nash
equilibria are stationary okay that's
good that's good to know but not very
useful
uh more interestingly more interestingly
if
an orbit of the dynamics converges the
limit has to be a nash equilibrium it
can converge nowhere else
uh
also
if a point is stable then it has to be a
nash equilibrium
all right there are no other stable
points
and moreover strict nash equilibria are
asymptotically stable and these are the
only
points the only equilibria that can be
asymptotically stable all right this is
exactly what we saw in the various
pictures that i showed so far and this
is
the first the first dynamic
uh
a
dynamic interpretation
reinterpretation rather of the
instability i was talking about
regarding mixed equilibria yes
actually the person from the
does not depend on the regulatory
notable
what happens to this dynamics with
stochastic rewards
like like people that just has the
bandwidth let's just eliminate the
let me get to the second part where we
have because here everything is
deterministic let me get to the second
part in this three times you have a
stochastic uh everything will be
surpassed
yes sorry two questions yeah um
isn't it for revelator dynamics that you
started the boundary and not the
interior
super
super uh so first of all uh
in terms of evolutionary in terms of
revolutionary games population games
this would correspond to multi
population of evolutionary games all
right
in multi population games not single
population it is very different in multi
population random games
every definition of
evolutionary stability is equivalent to
strict nash equilibrium it is in single
population only that you can have
that you have evolutionary stable states
that may not be
um
that may not be
strict nash equilibria that was the
first part of the operation the second
part is
uh
look at what i said here this uh this
queue in the case of the replicator
dynamics would be the exponential
mapping because we're interested in
learning so these are all things that
are coming from some learning
initialization so these things
by necessity in the case of the
replicator dynamics leaving the interior
of the simplex or at least start of the
interior of the simplex this might not
be the case if you have a non-steep
regularizer but in the case of the
replicator dynamics these are actually
interior trajectories
any more questions
okay
all right
so
uh well i wanted to give a some a some
more details about what happens in the
zero sum in the min max case
uh i'll have to go a bit uh a bit fast
unfortunately here but what you can show
is that this entire class when you have
a min max a finite min max game with an
interior equilibrium then
the dynamics admit a constant of motion
and environment all right and not only
that
you can also show i'm gonna skip this
this slide you can also show that
they are volume preserving under a
certain uh under a certain romanian
metric which
has to do
which is
obtained by uh by the regularizer
uh if you combine these uh if you
combine these two elements
you can show
that uh well there is some work that
needs to be done it's not that simple
unfortunately but you can show
that uh
well i said here rd this should be the
ftrlc all the dynamics if you will have
this property you can show that uh
all these regularized learning dynamics
are one career recurrent in all
min max games with a full support
equilibrium what does this mean
it means first of all it means that no
matter where you start
you will always return arbitrarily close
to your starting point infinitely many
times
all right
this is the definition of ponca
recurrence and this explains precisely
the type of cycling that we saw in the
case of minimax of
minimax games
i mean like finite games all right
so i don't have i don't want to spend
too much here i mean i don't have too
much time so i'm gonna run through and
go to
the second part
uh which has to do with
uh
the case of learning what is more
interesting perhaps to us what happens
when we're learning in discrete time all
right so here
we have the same underlying primitives
we have a finite game
uh
here however the time is discrete
at every point at every time uh players
choose a mixed strategy then they choose
a mix they choose a pure strategy based
on this mixed strategy and
they can now receive very different
types of feedback
they could see the entire mixed payoff
vector this is the best case the
telepathic case they could see only they
realized the pure payoff vector all
right
or they could only have access to bandit
information meaning they only observe
their reward and that's that all right
and we'd like to study what happens
when we now vary the feedback
requirements of the algorithm
here
yes i don't think i need to go through
this
what is important
first of all is to uh
is to see whether uh especially for the
bandit case it is important to see
whether we can somehow map it
or lift it to a certain vector type
valued uh vector valued information and
whether it is possible to somehow
estimate the payoffs of actions that we
did not play all right so of course if
the only information that we have is the
reward that we got
well really we can't however what we can
do is we can introduce what is known as
an importance weighted estimator which
is uh which is uh simply a random vector
constructed which assigns zero to all
strategies that
to the payoff of all strategies that
were not played and weighs the payoff
that we actually observed by dividing by
the probability with which we chose it
all right
this importance weighted estimator which
is extremely important in in the theory
of multi-around bandits has the
fundamental property that it is unbiased
so
if we uh so an expectation it is equal
exactly to the tail vector that we are
trying to estimate and it has a
finite though not necessarily bounded
variance
or moment second moment in this case
all right
so uh why am i saying this because uh
with this type with this type of
importance rated estimation we can
actually
model
all these types of feedback we can
actually uh
uh
put them into the same bag or into this
bag of it of a so-called sfo model a
stochastic first order oracle model in
which we can simply assume that players
receive as information
some
estimate of their or well either they
receive or they construct some
estimate uh some estimate of their
payoff vector at
stage n and this payoff vector could
have
both uh
sorry both uh some random noise in it
but also some system some systematic
error which is kind of which might be
coming from the estimation process
all right
now as i said
the instructive the instructive case
here it is instructive to look at the
three types of feedback that would be
that we discussed in the case when
players observe their mixed payoff
vectors then there is no noise there is
no bias
when they observe their pure payoff
vector
there is
some noise bound noise and no bias
and uh
when they only observe the realized uh
payoffs the importance weighted
estimator that they can construct based
on this information
it leads to
no bias
but
uh noise with a
significantly higher albeit finite
variant
all right
so
to
understand a bit what happens when we
try to learn with this type of
information
uh
in the case of if we now look at the
exponential weights algorithm
uh well it follows the exact same path
as the its continuous time counterpart
only that of course
what can really change here is the type
of feedback available to the players at
each stage
so
in case uh if we have mixed paper vector
observations then we have a
deterministic algorithm again no bias no
noise no nothing
if we have a pure vector observation as
i said we have no bias
and the bounded variance
this algorithm is actually known as
hedge
uh the x3 algorithm corresponds to the
use of the exponential weight templates
with importance weighted estimation and
this has no bias and variance uh
which is finite but unbounded
so to correct this uh it is usual to
introduce uh some explicit exploration
in the algorithm in which case you
introduce some bias that you control by
playing with a certainly a certain small
probability uniformly on the simplex
instead of drawing a strategy with your
predicated
mixed strategy
but the good thing is that yes you pay
the price in terms of bias but you can
now control the variance or the second
moment of the uh of the of the algorithm
all right so this is x3 with explicit
exploration
you can even go for you can even cover
other algorithms like optimistic uh
optimistic variants uh in uh there is
another algorithm known as optimistic
multiplicative ways update or of
optimistic exponential waves whether
whatever name you want
which uh which was introduced by uh by
kostis and janice by corsisa scalias and
janspanayas and which runs by first
doing a test update based on past
information and then uh querying
uh clearing the state to be to get a new
payoff vector et cetera et cetera
what is important is that this is a
deterministic algorithm so there's no
randomness involved
there is no noise but there is bias
because uh because the type of vectors
that you that you are getting do not
concern the actual states
that you the actual strategy that you
played but a sort of leading strategy
that you sampled
you can go you can take this idea even
further there is a very recent uh
algorithm called
clairvoyant
how 10 minutes yeah okay i'm good
uh
you can run exponential weights with
what is known as clairvoyant feedback in
which you assume that you can somehow uh
that you can somehow
predict or you're clairvoyant enough and
you can predict the payoff that you the
payoff vector that you will get at
the strategy in which you will land
all right so i think uh jorgus will talk
about this about this model so uh in
later this week so i will not
get into the into details of this
i just want to say that this also can be
cast as part of this uh of of this
general model
again it is a deterministic implicit
algorithm uh which has bias the bias is
simply the difference between the
clairvoyant state and the and your
actual state
and uh as i said since it is
deterministic there is no variance there
is no variance because there is no noise
component
and all that all right
so
we can
keep playing this game we can change the
regularizer and start talking about
extra gradient optimistic gradient
methods etc etc i don't want to do that
i just want to i just wanted to show
that this sfo model this stochastic
first order oracle model is really quite
flexible and that can can accommodate a
lot of algorithms and so i want to i
just wanted to give you an idea of the
spectrum of algorithms that you can uh
that you can put in this in this
umbrella
ah
the second
umbrella component of regularized
learning process has to do with the
actual
uh well updating scheme which again
follows the same regularized updates
that we had in continuous time
only that now we need to
uh we need to put some more technical
requirements for the regularizer it is
no longer sufficient to assume that you
are running your method with any
strictly convex spontaneous regularizer
you would need to assume that it is
strongly convex
and that it uh it admits its
subdifferential admits a continuous
selection basically that it is
differentiable on the interior of the
stage space all right
these are uh some technical conditions
that well you need in order to do the
the analysis of this type
of uh of methods
uh
again
i will skip this since we've talked
about several examples so i don't think
i need to explain this in more detail
your
i just want to show you what happens
with the pro with the type of portraits
that we had before so here in these
figures what am i doing uh you have in
green here these continuous curves are
exactly the same curves that i showed
you before for the replicator dynamics
what i'm running on top of them is
optimistic multiplicative weights with a
constant step size
all right and this is the type of random
works that you get on the simplex as a
result
and you can see
that they
at least in this case they somehow
uh follow the
qualitative the qualitative uh
convergence properties of the under of
the underlying mean dynamics
pretty well i mean you observe the same
type of
uh equilibrium convergence properties
the dynamics converts to these
to these uh to district equilibria so do
the
so does optimistic multiplicative waves
and the interior equilibrium that is
somewhere here i just forgot to draw it
is of course again unstable if even if
you start on the on its stable manifold
again this goes to i think your question
about uncertainty and noise you see that
when you have
noise uh
of course
is makes any neutrally stable state
it destroys any chance of convergence
well okay perhaps i'm taking some poetic
liberty and saying destroys any chance
please give me some rope on this
the question is whether it may we at
least maintain the convergence
properties to strict equilibria here all
right
well yeah
of course we have to play a role i mean
otherwise
where does the work
so
if i reverse the image of the
coordination game you say it's basically
the same profile
[Music]
matching penis is perhaps more
interesting because in the case of
matching paintings what we had is is
this nice foliation of the state space
into
periodic into a continuous
specter of periodic orbits now we're
losing that
we're losing that and we are converging
to
uh the boundary in
whereas in previous dilemma we are
following
the
we are following the
mean dynamics quite closely
so
uh
the question is whether we can get a
similar result as a continuous time
well here things are stochastic so we
need to change the definition of what
stability means
uh
to account exactly for the randomness in
the process so now we're saying that the
point is stochastically stable basically
if it is stable with sufficiently high
probability this is this delta this is
this confidence level over here
and we're saying that a point is
stochastically asymptotically stable if
it is stochastic stable and attracting
again with
a sufficiently high probability
and the main result here is the
following that
for this entire class of algorithms that
we that we discussed so remember there
are two axis first of all there is the
regularizer axis which covers uh which
goes from uh exponential weights to log
barrier dynamics to
a projection to projection type dynamics
to childish type dynamics and there is
the feedback axis which allows us to
cover multiplicative weights optimizing
multiplicative weights
uh clairvoyant with different types of
feedback and all that all right so for
this entire class of algorithms
there are some
somehow arcane assumptions that you need
to make for the bias and or
or the
or the state size of the method but if
you specify to a specific uh to a
specific
step size then uh
you get that
any sequence generated by uh by this
generalized ftrl type of processes
satisfies the following properties again
if it convergence its limit is a nash
equilibrium with probability one
if it is stochastically stable then it
is a nash equilibrium
and
it a state is stochastically
asymptotically stable if and only if it
is a strict nash equilibrium so again
we see here that one part
was was to be expected if in continuous
if in continuous time the only stable
points are
the only asymptotically stable points
are the strict nash equilibria then in
this under uncertainty we cannot expect
other points to somehow become stable
what is
so what is considerably harder here is
this direction to show that strict nash
equilibria remain stochastically
asymptotically stable even
with uh even under uncertainty uh with
banded feedback and all that
and not only that you can actually
estimate the rate of convergence to
strict nash equilibria which now this
actually depends on the regularizer so
if you have a regularizer which is like
the entropic one
which is rather exactly the entropic one
you get a geometric convergence rate
geometric in the sum of the step sizes
so if you run the algorithm the constant
step size you get
convergence in log converges to an
epsilon strict nash equilibrium within
one within log of one over epsilon
iterations
what is even more interesting is that if
you run the dynamics with
uh
a euclidean regularizer
then
you converge to the strict natural
equilibrium in a finite number of
iterations with probability one
all right
and this is for me uh
quite interesting because it highlights
a sort of a dichotomy between no regret
learning
regret minimization policies and
equilibrium learning because in in terms
of regret you would actually like to run
a multiplicative ways exponential
weights because it is these types of
algorithms that have better dimension
and better degrees in terms of the
dimensionality of the game
however if you are interested in
convergence 201 equilibrium
the
right regularizer even in the case of
banded feedback
is the euclid 1 1 because this gives you
convergence to exactly strict nash
equilibrium
in uh in a fight number of iterations
so this tension uh
between no regret learning and
equilibrium learning was something that
was also observed by
uh i mean again if you were here last
week in videos talk
and it definitely um
is not the end of the story i mean there
is definitely a lot to understand for
the interval regarding the interplay
between no regret learning and
equilibrium learning when we're talking
about the actual sequence of play and
not its empirical frequency and when
we're talking about nash equilibrium not
some very course generalization like
they're of like a cc
and
also i mean
in terms of algorithms even though the
class that we started is uh is quite
large in itself uh there are still many
things to left to be done like study
what happens when we have an adaptive
step size or when we have delays or
corruption
etc etc but yeah question
so this is really
that there are no
the regret matching uh process is not a
regularized process precisely because it
matches the entire history so it is
different for regret matching this does
not
um
yeah i mean i guess that's it so we can
take questions some more questions
any any questions from the audience
what does this mean your results say
something that
the projection dynamics have small
regret too
because no no no no no i'm i'm not uh
i hear this is a pure equilibrium
convergence your dog this is the only
thing this is the only thing that we
study
uh
you can study if you can run it with
projection type dynamics banded feedback
uh the standard analysis of fcrl would
apply in that case and it would give you
a regret
which is square root t
but square root the uh square no
[Applause]
uh no because if you run it with
with explicit exploration
you will get actually uh regret with
your t to the two two thirds
so
this is one this is why i'm saying that
uh
uh
there seems to be this tension between
no regret learning
at least with but with bandit feedback
if we're in the case of realization
based feedback things are much easier
because they're the
dimension and the
dependence on the dimensionality of the
game is
basically much much much smaller so
so you can still get square root of t
and
good dimensionality bounds
any other questions from the other end
so putting this back
into context uh does that mean that the
uncoupled non convergence result does
not hold for strict nash equilibria
um
sorry it seems that my computer died
um
[Music]
again yeah so putting this back into
context with the uncoupling this result
um does this mean for strict natural
equilibria uh that couple uncoupled
dynamics do converge the last result yes
does mean that okay uh to be clear the
counter example of uh heart health
had to do with an interior building okay
awesome
[Music]
any other questions from the audience
maybe maybe a question for me so
so what yeah so maybe what do we know in
the game that doesn't have a strictness
then
so
any
any thoughts on that uh let me see it
like that
all right okay great so
no strict enough uh
a
no strict knife means no convergence to
the point
this is this this is what this is what
you you would get so then you might be
interested uh for me this is a very
important question because this uh you
might want to examine what type of sets
you might end up converging to
if at all
and identifying the structure of the
attractors and or
what other type of sets now can be uh
can be stable under regularized learning
for me this is this is a very uh very
open but also very difficult uh very
difficult research a research expression
there are some partial results but not
not a full characterization as to what
at least there is definitely not a
pleasant uh characterization like uh any
family if uh
theorem that uh like the one that i
showed so this is very often this is
very open and quite challenging in my
opinion
awesome good
any any last question
if not let's thank uh
[Music]